the fate of the multiverse
depends on us
so a new promo advertising the tickets
for doctor strange and multiverse of
madness has just released and there's a
lot of new footage and dialogue so let's
just get straight into it so the trailer
starts off with dialogue from doctor
strange and wonders saying i've been
dreaming the same dream every morning
the same
nightmare the first new shot we have
here is of doctor strange who is on the
floor and it looks like he is being
newly handcuffed he is taken captive if
we look in the background he seems to be
in some type of enclosement now i think
this is the same one we see of him and
america chavez in that previously
released picture we have the next new
shot is of wonder and her kids from one
division confirming her kids will play a
part in this new film she's holding her
kids and then it cuts to a shot of her
holding thin air this is from the show
where she was seen previously meditators
and basing off the dialogue that we've
seen before she has obviously had a
dream of this or she's had a vision of
her holding her kids because we all know
that she wants her kids back we have a
couple new shots here with wong in the
background saying the fate of the
multiverse depends on us we then cut to
a shot of who i believe is sinister
strange and he has a third eye in the
scene strange himself is very confused
by this appearance of sinister strain so
i'm guessing this is their first
encounter with each other and strange
seeing this third eye on sinister
strange just responds with okay and then
i cut a quick shot of him attacking
sinister strange so it looks like we'll
be getting at least one fight between
the two of them so that's pretty much
about it for this new promo it's really
exciting to see more footage from this
film i cannot wait for it and i'm
excited to finally pick up some tickets
for this film so let me know in the
comment section below what you think of
this new footage and if you haven't
already please like and subscribe and
turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching